c'est en régie il va être dans l'oreille
de patrice laffont patrice laffont non
mais c'est vrai vous et vous devez
répéter tout ce que vous dit pas c'est
toi d'accord c'est mon nom mais
n'écoutez pas ceux qui vous diraient
avant le lâcher j'ai des trucs qui sont
pris dans le suma le mettre là comme
j'étais quoi attention patrice c'est
quoi la première chose que tu fais le
matin en se réveillant je fais pipi je
fais pipi et après je me lève et après
je me lève je vois des nouvelles de
pepita de pyramide
oui oui elle vient juste de s'y repérer
elle s'appelle pepito
[Applaudissements]
si tu devais résumer ta carrière en un
mot je devais résumer ta carrière en un
mot patrice consonnes bacon sonne pas
mal
ou peut-être voyait le principal défaut
de laurent romejko c'est une merde c'est
une petite merde non la discipline
peut-être sont pas fils vous savez
maintenant
non non est une petite merde avant
déchets posent encore du shit aux
enfants des forums et ce coup bas semble
qu'elle est la dernière personne au
monde que tu aimerais voir en couple
avec ta fille
christian quesada aujourd'hui si tu
devais démarrer une carrière de youtube
heures tu prendrais quoi comme pseudo
patrice l'option
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah dommage qu'elle ait l'émission de
télé qui te fait le plus rêver
50 minutes inside minutes inside
il faut développer parce que mon record
actuellement ces trois minutes bon
[Rires]
est-ce que tu as un petit tatouage
cacher un tatouage un petit jouet g1
boyard sur l'anus oui mais tu oses jadis
vraiment j'ai un brouillard sur l'anus
[Applaudissements]
savoyard soit nu et là qui s'arrête pas
je crois en moi parce que les bailleurs
c'est très cool il faut avoir la clé
c'est quoi la plus grosse erreur de ta
vie non je n'ai pas commis beaucoup
d'erreurs a dit avec sept ans que je
suis les deux c'est julien lepers
sauf avec de gila le père c'est à dire
non je ne dirais pas cet [ __ ] gina
lepers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]